across the uk we take it for granted
that if a fire breaks out
you can call an emergency number
firefighters will arrive they'll do
their best to save lives and put out the
fire
and you will not get sent to bill for
making that call
sure if some movie director's arranged a
massive pyrotechnic stunt for a movie
and they need firefighters standing by
just in case something goes wrong
they'll probably pay for the time there
but in everyday life
firefighters are funded by government
through taxes
for everyone but that's not always been
the case
the great fire of london in 1666 lasted
for four
days the idea of firefighters hadn't
really been invented at that point
the great fire was only stopped by a
change in the wind and by the military
blowing up houses to create a fire break
the whole of central london burned to
the ground
rebuilding took 30 years the enormous
monument
on the site where the fire started is
still standing today
350 years later after the great fire the
job of fire protection in london
was taken up by insurance companies
building owners would pay a fee for a
few years coverage
and the insurance company would attach a
metal fire mark to the front of the
building
like these on the wall of st james
palace
so in 18th century london if a fire
broke out and smoke started rising
several fire brigades each run by a
different insurance company
would all rush to the scene and then
they'd check for fire marks
and only fight the fire if they saw
their own company's mark
or the mark of a company they had an
agreement with if the building wasn't
insured
they would let it burn their job was
protection of property not life
if a neighbouring building was insured
with them and the fire looked to be
spreading that way well
yes it'd make sure that building was
safe of course and it wasn't just london
there were similar schemes all around
the country and around the world
if firefighters standing aside while
building burns
seems immoral to you well there are lots
of places where that's still the case
today or where firefighting companies
will send
a bill afterwards assuming that an
insurance company will pay it
in places where there aren't enough
people or there's not enough political
will
for a government-funded fire service
that may still be the only option
in london it wasn't until 1833 that 10
of those insurance companies
joined their fire brigades together to
create a single
fire service still private in 1866
the government finally took over and
created the london fire engine
establishment
as a public service but that was only
after another
major fire it took disaster it took
death and destruction
to move things forward to the point
where you can call the fire service to
save
lives not just property and without
having to worry about the bill
you can still see a few fire marks and
old buildings around london and around
the uk these days
although not all of them are original
some are recent reproductions put up for
a fact heck
those on the walls of the palace might
be reproductions for all i know but
fortunately it doesn't matter because
firefighters don't have to check for
them anymore
that was going to be a really good shot
at buckingham palace and all you're
going to see is the traffic light
i don't know why i thought i'd be able
to get a good zoom shot of buckingham
palace from there
the road's closed by the way i'm just
going to make that turn and just walk
out into
an active road that's closed off for
pedestrians